من بريطانيا نتحول الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعتراف عالمي بان اماد هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا ماض في شهوره وربما سنوات
وعلى لسان عده شخصيات اوروبيه اجمع ضمنيا
في كل تصريحاتها على قول واحد ان الحرب
ستكون طويله الامل من بين هؤلاء الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو جوترش الذي
اعرب عن اماله بانتهاء الحرب في عام 2023
بالرغم من كونه لا يرى اي احتمال لاجراء
محادثات سلاما في المستقبل القريب ويعتزم
الاتحاد الاوروبي فرضا حزمه جديده من
العقوبات الاقتصاديه على موسكو خلال
المرحله المقبله بعد ما اقر التكتل المكون
من سبع و20 دوله 9 حزم من العقوبات منذ
بدء الهجوم في فبراير من عام 2020 حتى
امين حلف الناتو
هابي فمن الان لا تستهين بروسيا رغم
انتكاسها يجب ان نستعد لحرب طويله الامل
[موسيقى]
مواصله وتعزيز دعمنا لاوكرانيا لاننا
راينا ان روسيا كبدت خسائر كبيره بسبب
الجنود الاوكرانيين الشجعان الذين يتمتعون
بكفاءه المهنيه ويمارسون ذلك بتفان لكن
يجب ان لا نقلل من شان روسيا انهم يحشدون
المزيد من القوات ويعملون جاهدين للحصول
على المزيد من المعدات والذخيره وقد
اظهروا استعدادا للمعاناه فعليا لمواصله
الحرب كما لا يوجد مؤشر على تغيير الرئيس
بوتين للهدف العام لحربه ضد اوكرانيا لذلك
نحن بحاجه الى الاستعداد لحرب طويله
وبهذه الاعترافات يجد الغرب نفسه في شبه
ماء ازرق ويتحول من المسانده الى المصارحه
ليسال نفسه ماذا عن جاهزيتنا لو طال امل
هذه الحرب صحيفه وصف جون الامريكيه اشارت
الى ان الحرب كلما طال امدها ستصب في
مصلحه روسيا رغم انها تكبدت بعض الخسائر
في الاونه الاخيره بل ان روسيا تراهن على
فقدان الغرب الحماس تحديدا امل ها في ان
تشب الخلافات بين الدول حول مؤيد
لاوكرانيا ومعارض لها حتى الان لم تحقق
ايا من الرهانات والدليل ان اوروبا خلصت
اعتمادها على الطاقه الروسيه دون كوارث
السياسيه لكن الصحيفه تاكدت انه هو برغم
ذلك فان الحرب الطويله ستكون لصالح موسكو
واوروبا ليست مستعده لهذا النوع من الحروب
ولا حتى الولايات المتحده ففي الماضي حولت
روسيا اقتصادها الى اقتصادها حرب في
المقابل لم تقم واشنطن ولا حلفائها باجراء
اي تعديلات في الانتاج العسكري
لنختصر قليلا ما قالته الصحيفه ببساطه ان
روسيا دمرت صناعه الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وجعلتها تعتمد على الاسلحه الغربيه لكن
مشتريات الدفاع الغربيه وعمليه التصنيع
على عكس روسيا تلتزمان الى حد كبير
بالاجراءات والجداول الزمنيه في اوقات
السلم
ورغم مصادقتي الكونغرس الامريكي الشهر
الماضي على حزمه مساعدات بقيمه
44.9 مليار دولار لدعم اوكرانيا لكن سيطره
الجمهوريين على مجلس النواب تعني ان
التمرير المزيد من هذه المساعدات العسكريه
والمدنيه لك يافا سيكون اكثر تعقيده
وانجاز القول فان روسيا امنت على
احتياجاتها العسكريه فمن ناحيه المعدات
الحربيه هي تواصل تصنيع ما يلزم من
الذخائر وتوسع انتاجها لمواكبتي وتيره
القتال خاصه بعد ان وعد درس طول امد الحرب
مبكر واذا ما قرنا القوه العامله فانها
ايضا بحسب والسجون لتصب في صالح روسيا
التي حلت هذه المشكله وحشدت 300,000 جندي
احتياطي كما يبلغ عدد سكان روسيا 3.5
اضعاف عدد سكان اوكرانيا اي ان روسيا حتى
لو خسرت جنديين مقابل كل جندي اوكراني فان
المعادله البشريه تثبت قوه النسبيه لروسيا
واكدت الصحيفه ان التعبئه الاخيره سمحت
للرئيس بوتن بتحقيق الاستقرار في خط
المواجهه وشان هجوم مضاد حول مدينه بخموت
في منطقه شرق اوكرانيا وفي هذا المضمار
ولا ايفو دالدار سفير الولايات المتحده
السابق لدى النتو الذي يراس مجلس شيكاغو
للشؤون العالميه ان اي فكره عن عمليه
السلام قد ولات لان بوتا يبذل قصار جهده
للتاكيد على ان الحرب باتت معركه وجوديه
بالنسبه لحم مقابل ذلك فان ادوارد سترينجر
الرئيس السابق للعمليات في هيئه اركان
الدفاع البريطانيه يارا ان الغرب يدعم
اوكرانيا بالقطار اي ما يكفيها فقط كي لا
تخسر حاليا
وبفعلته هذا فانه يطيل امد الحرب بيديها
هذا بالاضافه لازمه اخرى تتعلق باروقه
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه في تركيا
ابراهيم كالون ان بلاده ليست في وضع يسمح
لها بالموافقه على طلب انضمام السويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي تصريحات كالين هي احدث
موقف تركيا غاضبا من تظاهره في ستوكهولم
تقول انقره ان ان صار حزب العمال
الكردستاني علقوا فيها دميه لاردوغان في
تصرف وصفه الاتراك بالمهين كانن قال ايضا
ان احاله ملف انضمام ستوكهولم وهلسنكي الى
البرلمان ربما سيكون في يونيو اي حتى يصوت
البرلمان السويدي على تشريعه طلبه تركيا
الغضب التركي تصاعد بعد رفض السويد تسليمه
بولند كنيتش احد المطلوبين لدى تركيا
وكذلك موافقه الحكومه على وقف تسليم اربعه
مطلوبين الى انقره في ضوء هذه التطورات
سيعقد اجتماعه ثلاثي بين تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا قريبا ربما تستضيفه بروكسل وقال
وزير الخارجيه التركي ان بلاده قبلت حضور
الاجتماع